good afternoon and thank you for
inviting me city & Co now well i'm very
new to this community not so new to the
area though have learned i heard about
differential privacy a little over a
year ago 14 15 months ago so i'm
enjoying it this is joint work with my
students want and my colleague say whoa
oh saebom couldn't be here he's giving a
colloquium talk at Stanford I don't now
all right
play that works okay i'm new to
differential privacy but I work in an
area called information theory which is
yeah which is the following ok so it's
among many things it's the following
where it's basically the mathematical
theory behind communication so you have
some data and the diet needs to be
somehow communicated from one point to
another point along the way you have a
physical channel and some physical
resources so this is like the underlying
mechanism behind all data transfer wires
wireless whatever I would like to say
that there's a various connection here
so the thing is the what you get is not
what you send there's a channel in
between and that's random and that's
usually in nature so we have statistical
models and we just work with them
sometimes we work with worst-case models
too and the designer or the engineer
gets to decide the encoding and decoding
functions and the goal in to end is to
have a small error probabilities a
privacy I look at it through these
lengths of information theory at least
differential privacy looks it has
similar block diagrams you have data and
instead of encoding you think of it as a
query which I just put down as nature
but it could be something else like what
the database is queried with so where is
something let's say I call it nature
sanitization is what I get to design
adversary works tries to do the best
decoding and tries to learn something
about the data the and the thing is it's
a similar block diagrams different
things are getting bit designed but in
privacy we want large error
probabilities there's another difference
which is in communication I think of it
information seal I think of it as multi
hypothesis testing so I think of data as
many possible values and I want to get
all the exactly right so it's a multiple
hypothesis testing problem differential
privacy though works with the user being
there or not so it's really binary
hypothesis testing I should say that it
could be any user so
many binary hypothesis testing so it's
multi binary hypothesis tests okay and
this is smaller probability larger
probabilities because it's binary
hypothesis testing their only two types
of errors this false alarm miss
detection type 1 type 2 and throughout
this talk I'm going to plot these curves
they're all ameen for the statistics
community this would be an ROC curve of
almost except instead of plotting 1
minus probability of Miss detection and
plotting just the probability of errors
and differential privacy the approximate
differential privacy says that both
errors false alarm in this detection
should be large enough I'm going to use
this diagram will be a throughout pretty
much in nearly every slight so let's get
the notation right so there's I'm just
plotting error probabilities there's a
binary hypothesis test the user is there
or not and as long as the error
probabilities are in this red region you
say the mechanism is epsilon delta
differentially private notice that this
height is Delta this I guess this
intercept here is Delta the slope is e
to the negative epsilon okay so that is
the parameters epsilon and Delta this is
not exactly how of course so
differential privacy was defined so I
should just say quickly when Delta is 0
or you just have this triangle type of a
thing as opposed to a pentagonal
structure which today with Delta all
right this not exactly how it was
originally posted post as a ratio the
log the likelihood ratios are between
you to the epsilon and e to the negative
epsilon or the log likelihood ratios are
between epsilon and negative Epsilon but
it's known that equivalently it's just
in fact it's an exact equivalence this
is implied but it's also true the other
way and so it's really a very tight
connection the reason I want to say this
is because informations result driven by
operational connections to hypothesis
testing it's a very critical of step
information theory is a metro area I
don't think this is Polly mech so I
think it taken safe to say this it's
been around for a while and it's been
successful two and one and among many
things one of the successful things that
theory has done is to identify extremal
limits to how well you can do the
encoding and decoding and
hence get two fundamental benchmarks in
particular we are interested in the
communication context we are interested
in the maximal rate you can do reliable
communication orbit reliable
communications called capacity of
channels and so forth so I mean having
understandings extremal limits as many
benefits one of them is to set
fundamental limits lower bounds it also
provides insight into practical schemes
that get close to achieving it and much
of these results are derived through a
lens of hypothesis testing so this is
the so-called operational interpretation
and hope it brings value see mostly
because it gives insight to how you are
doing the probes but also because
they're just technically strong data
processing inequalities are strong okay
so that's the information theory story
and in this dog I would like to do a
similar program for differential privacy
I would like to identify extremal
mechanisms in this case a hand setting
fundamental lower bounds all along the
way using the lens of the binary
hypothesis testing operations nothing
new by say I mean this seems interesting
to anyone and so I have three types of
results to say in this context one I
will propose an external mechanism I
will call it staircase to get started
it's a noise adding mechanism so it's
got real numbers it's got algebra of
topology of real numbers and or integers
and stuff so you can add things and
furthermore it's only data independent
let's get started once we and once I try
to understand what's happening here will
derive composition theorems their exact
and once I even understand that the real
goal is that I will understand why this
was actually universally optimal
mechanism and so there's a notion of an
abstract staircase mechanism this is
neither knows nor is it adding but the
intuitions are all right here and it's
really the right mechanism it dominates
every other mechanism in a strong sense
I will precisely define what the senses
okay so that's the goal for the stock oh
yes
I'll be precise if you were just once
give me one minute yeah I'll be precise
about all these statements okay so I
said I just want to get started so I'm
new to the community in a sense I look
at the state of the art in the sense
what are mechanisms people use well I
looked at laplacian nice so that's
exponential mechanisms both sided I like
that Gaussian noise so it's rare to go
through an information theory paper
without Gaussian noise so we like that
I'll i understand it reasonably well and
there aren't any exact optimality
results so I think about it and I look
for other mechanisms just around in the
literature and I find this one which is
for integer valued queer it's not real
valued these are integer valued and
let's specifically fix count queries
where the sensitivity is just one and
then there is a mechanism which is to
add geometric noise and this one has
optimality property it's universally
optimal in a certain cost minimization
framework over sort of most interesting
costs but you're sort of asian prior on
the input there's no operational meaning
in the sense that is a sort of a
functional analytic proof decision
theoretic probe which is good but I just
point out that since I look at the
lengths of my binary hypothesis tests
the likelihood ratios are between the
epsilon and negative epsilon but for
this particular mechanism they're only
the extremes okay so let's just keep
this in mind we'll think about it as we
go along so I thought about the
staircase mechanism and so we thought
about it and here's a generalization the
same integer setting one single count
query so to answer Cynthia's just one
query the same setting as before one
query and this time I allow sensitivity
more than one and I also consider a
worst-case inputs so there's no prior on
the input its worst case car first case
over the inputs and I would like to
minimize the worst case the cost
and where we look at that and we find
the universal mechanism it's not
geometric anymore it's if delta equals
one it will become geometric but
otherwise it has this staircase shape
okay that's the name staircase again now
if you look at our proof there's no
operational interpretation operational
at least intuition it's sort of
functional analytic proof and I just
point out that among their again the log
of the likelihood ratios are between
epsilon and negative Epsilon but this
time they can take it takes only three
values the two extremes or zero yeah
Sasha what is the cost I haven't defined
it so that's the next life thank you so
do you explain that the graph in more
detail what is so this is the PMF so I
could have plotted I guess the geometric
noise the geometric noise would have
been like this it takes only integers
and like this this one has flats and
then it jumps down flat jump down in the
colors ok so I'll there is a coding for
the color and two more slides humber
that this is a PMF of the noise the
probability mass function and if you
want to think of it as probabilistically
it's a geometric mixture of uniform
random variables these are uniform
random variables and where they are is
geometrically mixed it's a discrete
geometric mixture of discrete uniform
random variables Delta is lesson one no
this is an integer value old so Delta
can never be anything less so Delta is
an integer these are all integer values
so this is the request Bible now in this
particular case one two three four five
exactly and the colors have a meaning in
da hang on for two more sites and Sasha
asked for the cost so this is the right
mechanism universally cost minimizing
mechanism for all these kind of costs I
look at this of noise adding so this was
not data dependent in general so their
special very special
I you I advice and I look at the cost
which is any function of the noise and
the average of that and any function
well not any but anything sensible that
means it's sort of symmetric around zero
that's the symmetric part and then there
it's more noise means more cost so it's
monotonically increasing this this
setting is very similar to the the Delta
equal to one the GRS the paper okay very
similar in fact the same set the only
difference really is that they were
doing base you setting this is worst
case is and this is just one query at
this point just integer value this makes
it and then I independent so we'll get
to all of ya the GRS paper didn't assume
the exactly so so I don't miss totally
right so the GRS proof work for data
independent and so it was true it was a
universal one even if you allow data
dependence turns out if you although if
you make some technical assumptions
among the class of such functions with
more Delta it's also true but that at
this point let's not forget there so
that's a good point Thank You Adam so
just that I will follow you what exactly
is therefore what do you mean with delta
equals 10 I say sorry so we need to
understand that part so delta equals 1
delta sensitivity and this is a global
sensitivity and one means it's a count
query so having a user or not and only
change the value of doubt very output by
one and these are integer values thank
you that's true
this is an important set up is this
clear this is the probability mass
function of the noise the total thing
comes to one so it's really a PMF
probability mass function this is
discrete random variable so it's okay
and this is the setting in which it's
Universal its data independent noise a
day if you put some technical conditions
on the class of data dependencies yeah
so mean we can talk more but yeah let's
move on okay so i won't say that the
paper has more detail i could also think
about real valued and there is a natural
generalization to go from integer to
real valued and it sort of looks like
this again there's a color coding and we
come to it I said two slides or maybe
three okay so it's a generalization at
this time this is a PDF probability
density function okay so here's how it
looks like so this is a closer look with
all the colors in full display every a
width that every color has width equal
to beta so first thing you see is that
this PDF has is periodic to some there's
some periodicity property and every
color has width exactly Delta so its
period it's periodic with period Delta
except for sort of the starting point
you jump in a certain place I call this
fraction gamma a parts of that it's a
periodic with the width Delta and the
jumps are always exponential so that is
the exponential discrete random variable
it's exactly an e to the negative
epsilon jump from step to step so the
colors really represent to what where
you first start off with and that's this
fraction gamma and that some number
between 0 1 and that you get to tune as
a function of your cost per as a based
on your cost function okay get to tune
this gamma so instead so i was kidding
in some sense in the sense that cheated
a little bit by saying this is the
universal one actually it's not the it's
a family
of universal functions one of which you
have paid based on the cost function but
it's parametrized by just one number
between 0 1 the whole family's parameter
is by just one number 0 between 0 and 1
so if you can look at what so here's a
special cost function which is the
magnitude of the noise with the
magnitude and you can explicitly
calculate I say so I said I have to tune
gamma based on the cost function but for
special cost functions you can actually
solve it by hand there is no it's also
seven functional equation it's so you
have to solve a functional equation in
gamma but as long as your cost functions
are polynomial inexpressible then it's
so you have to solve the polynomial
equation in gamma yes Sasha oh the first
is I had this property that you can add
noise former geometric distribution then
I can come and based on my cost function
I can do some post processing so what
you're saying is that this is not
happening here like you have to know my
cost function and add noise face I say
some okay that's true and say a little
bit more about universality of gamma 2
so I'll have just a bit more to say
that's exactly right I I need to pick
gamma are based on the cost function you
can check University and you pay a
little bit cause soil say just one slide
off about that that says just a bit on
that so let's look at special cost
functions like magnitude of X and you
can explicitly solve for gamma there's
some simple formula for it and you can
find the closed form expression for what
is the minimum cost and you can compare
it with the Laplace one and more or less
for high privacy they look very similar
the multiplicative gap is close to one
additive gap also goes to zero even as
epsilon goes to infinity 0 no privacy
though it's exponentially different so
this looks like 1 over epsilon that
looks like e to the negative epsilon low
privacy may not be interesting regime to
operate in but that's what the results
are so if you want to say in one
sentence no privacy cause exponentially
less same thing with the variance I put
down data simply because there's a
formula just a bit too long to write
down but
but this again a closed-form expression
but qualitatively the same thing the gap
is small and in high privacy and but in
law privacy is an exponential
improvement you just give me a sense of
scale like when you say hi privately no
privacy like yeah there's any of the
curve of the first like value of epsilon
yeah I you save a factor 2 or something
no in a fact very much in the earlier
slides I even had some figures plotting
plotting the variance is a function of
epsilon somewhere around 1.5 to 2
epsilon around to it the knee of the
curve sharply changes and at that point
is just the variance dramatically starts
reducing for for the staircase mechanism
somewhere around five I thought it was a
factor of okay maybe I should speak
about 10 yeah okay we have a paper side
we can look it up in another version of
the slides I had those graphs so sasha
was asked about gamma and cynthia
mentioned what that color coding is so
there is a certain gamma star which
depends on the cost function i can say a
few things at low privacy it should look
like just pretty much zero so you can
just shrink it down at high privacy it
should look like half the sensitivity so
just jump it exactly half in general i
have a 0 it will put the universal now i
see ok so in our journal version of the
paper there is a guess for gamma it
looks like half e to the negative
epsilon between 0 and half and there are
properties that say that that's a
universal guess you get this one once
and for all and the there's a theorem
about how would that works ok so are you
pick gamma to be half e to the negative
epsilon that's all it's a heuristic
guess with certain properties it meets
these new conditions
and basically the gamma that gamma star
depends on the cost function in a
functional way it'll solve a fixed point
functional equation and you just try to
understand unique sort of universal
solutions to this fixed point equation
and so we can discuss direct but the
heat is really this okay so this is
something i do want to point out that
among all the possible choices of the
likelihood ratio it really just takes on
three values so if the pairs are here
then the ratio is exactly one and then
the log likelihood ratio is zero if
these two other pairs then it's the
ratio is here the epsilon are you
depending on which where you pick so
those are the extremes but really take
only three values and there's something
about it so is it an intuition for where
this this this is almost true it'll
applauses for laplacian amiss right so
if the variance is large if one over
epsilon is large if epsilon is small
then most of the time you're in you know
if you're comparing two shifted copies
of the distribution you're either they
differ by exactly e to the plus epsilon
or even the of minus epsilon there's
some probability that you get a number
close to zero and then that then the
likelihood ratio but it's always a
smooth function break the log likelihood
ratio will be a smooth function for even
you I'd laplacian noises it'll be a
continuous function you'll have the
whole range will be right but it always
never yeah okay it could have a ship
it's a min yes is not getting dark I
guess the point I'm making was just that
most of the time you know meaning with
probability I don't know 1 minus epsilon
issue it'll be that the log like a ratio
will be either yo Dominic on the data
like you fry on the data no no
of the coin flips in there in the
Laplace noise you see it could be closed
do you think it's flattering the towers
then you've got exactly okay you know I
don't want to stop you can keep going
it's this yeah it's not discreet though
mean I just want to say that maybe I'm
leading you on but there's something
about this so we will talk about it this
is the iphone so it sort of a canonical
result in that sense that you can apply
so the flushing noise wherever you think
of it as noise IDing you can go at the
staircase mechanism and for kamal costs
nearly every case it works and
performance you just improves because
the costs are sort of universal and
improvement really come only at low
privacy free chips okay moderate to low
and i haven't talked about it so we can
look at exactly what numbers we want
depending on what numbers you like of F
for epsilon if epsilon now is five I
think that's what you said then maybe
this is a definitely worth doing but
epsilon phi is too large then maybe not
ok there's two limitations though ok so
among other things there's two
limitations one there's no intuition
intuition is a fuzzy thing and different
communities treated differently and the
community I come from really need
intuition we want it we really value it
the reason is this intuition helps us
generalize the results so you could say
it's a special this is noise i dying
data independent low privacy I'll
privacy but to really generalize we need
intuition we need to know why this is
working in other words I want to be able
to do data dependent squarely dependent
mechanisms abstract sometimes they don't
even they're not even now adding I want
to understand it so that's really the
reason to have that quantity to shun
along the way of course you never know
what else you discover when you try to
go for intuition okay so how do they get
this infusion the intuition has to come
from the hypothesis testing thinking
point of view and along the way I give
some hints so what value is it taking so
let's keep that in mind so I go plot the
false alarm this
action curves for the mechanisms I have
there are always within the triangle
remember because they have to be epsilon
zero differentially private in the very
first part of the talk I said it has to
be inside this so any curve you have has
to be inside this triangle that was the
original set up so you plot Laplace it
looks like this you plot the Gaussian
where gaussians are never epsilon zero
differentially private for any epsilon
and indeed no surprise there is no
triangle that can contain this blue line
you can never fit a triangle that
completely covers it so you always need
a little bit of slack here and here okay
so this is all known stuff you plot the
staircase state is roc curves look like
this it follows this line and then
there's a 45-degree line and then it
follows yeah okay so that's our next
slide are usually you want it go exactly
on the triangle if you do that then your
mechanism is somehow doing just the
right thing using as much flexibility as
I have for my privacy and doing no more
in something these are doing extras all
these are doing extra more than your
requirement why do more and then you
want to be as useful as possible means
you want to have a small error as
possible so you want to do just right
you want to hit the triangle exactly
right these things are too complicated
because for several things is one of the
things is that there are multiple query
outputs any integer value or any real
valued too many binary hypothesis tests
I was plotting only one pair and too
many things going on so let's try to
simplify and look at just one a special
case this is interesting in its own way
this is the let us say the query output
is just binary yes-or-no only two words
there's a natural mechanism which is
randomized response going back to Warner
in 1959 which s so you say yes or no
with some probability and so forth okay
for the buyer for the epsilon zero
differential privacy this is there's a
natural values to do to scaling or you
just either stay at zero you flip ok
it's potentially suboptimal in general
this looks reasonable but it could be
suboptimal in general you might need
more complicated even for the binary
input you might need more complicated
things for example in this to party yes
you're certain the two-party work they
needed an extra label s in their
protocol so maybe you'll see something
so let me go plot as for Malika says
what the ROC curve looks like the false
alarm is detection curve for this
randomized response and bingo it hits
exactly the triangle nothin more nothin
less it's right there and here's the
sharp result from Statistics classical
work that if you have any other
mechanism epsilon privacy that means it
has to be inside this triangle then it
can be simulated from the randomized
response so let me be precise if you
have any other mechanism with output Y
that there is meeting epsilon zero
differential privacy so it's inside this
triangle region there exists a Markov
chain so there is a way to simulate Y
from X or statistically there's a Joint
Distribution I can put on x and y such
that D XY is a Markov chain so this is
some happy to be here at Berkeley giving
a talk on a classical result by a
Berkeley the gentry statistician
blackwell so this is Blackwell's 1953
result comparison of two experiments
very short that when for binary
hypothesis testing when one ROC curve is
inside another then there is strictly
degraded that is a remark or change
relating this one can be simulated from
another once you understand it at this
level a big cam let us say go back to
the distributed I on computation and
simulate the protocol they had with the
randomized response so that's just as an
example so the binary case works out
quite nice randomized response is
optimal and furthermore it is the only
one to do anything else can be simulated
by it so there's no real reason to do it
once we understand there okay so there
is a generalization of this to
approximate differential privacy this
time it's not the two outputs you need
for labels but essentially what's
happening is that one of the labels you
will never make an error with some
probability Delta you just pass 0
exactly and with some probability one is
passed exactly so those are the two
extra labels and with probability 1
minus Delta you have two labels where
you normally flip okay so it's very
similar well if I just gives you that
slack to say the truth with probability
of same thing you go project it meets
the exact differential privacy region
it's not a triangle anymore it's this
pentagonal shape and that was the exact
one and again because of blackness
result if you have any other mechanism
epsilon delta mechanism you can simulate
it from this four-point mechanism this
is only one to do as long as all of this
is special for binary inputs so the
query output was just an S no question
question yes so I just the best for the
results are I assume a 2 message
mechanism or okay it allows like a
interactive okay so excellent question
so there's no interactive setting in the
blackwell ok so we can come to it so
maybe I shouldn't have put those
references you should have had it an
offline discussion but I know and
understand the distribute computation we
have interactions and so forth but in
the Blackwell sitting there is no such
thing as interaction you just have two
hypotheses theta is 0 or 1 or D is d1 d2
and you have a mechanism that you can
view it through X or through why and you
go plot the false alarm is detection
probabilities where the curve is one
inside another so there is no notion of
any interaction or it's just a comparing
to statistical experiments there's no
there's no operate they need no more
than just that ok once we understand
exactly for binary query outputs what
the right mechanisms are and when I say
right this is the only one it hits the
privacy mechanism and anything else can
be simulated from it composition
theorems come naturally they come
automatically
cause if you have Lex 82 credits now so
it's a bit like vector query two outputs
and we are doing the worst case over all
possible inputs then if you have any
other if you have any mechanism that's
doing whatever you would do you can
always make it less private by going
back to the binary one in each case and
so composition you can just work with
composing the randomized mechanisms let
me do epsilon zero for now for two
queries each query you just do
randomized respond separately and now
you have four possible values because
this woman yes no here is Lou here so is
it for possible values so composing to
perris is a matter of four input for out
to input for output and I even know the
exact probabilities there's a binomial
sort of calculation because each one is
a binary so in general is a binomial
formula and you can plot the again ROC
regions exactly as things compose and
other mechanisms can can be any other
mechanisms can only be sort of insiders
and these give you the sort of the
bounds on how much any McCann is an
oppressor comprise you compose lots of K
mechanisms even inter so at this point
I'm talking as with examples where I'm
not being interactive but when you do a
converse you can also do interactively
and there's no harm with it so you just
have generalized slightly Blackwell's
result with your condition on other
observations and if you do epsilon Delta
then you have to compose the pentagon's
but your such strong structure such
combinatorial structure for your
mechanisms that it's very
straightforward to calculate what the
composition region looks like 25 minute
talk we can only do so much but there's
a paper we can look at it so this is
from a region perspective this is
typically not how for example papers in
the literature or written when you
compose square is usually you look at
for a given Delta how much epsilon tilde
was the end-to-end composition how do
you go from
how do you go from the region to epsilon
delta sort of a characterization well
Delta is just the intercept and epsilon
the corresponding slope so that's how
you go from the region pips on delta
mean that is why we had this Pentagon
like that so men so this is the e to the
epsilon is the slope e to the negative
epsilon is the slope and the intercept
estate so for any data you take the
intersect and look at the slope that
hits the that contains with them so here
we have a binomial structure I know
exactly what my curves look like and for
any data I can go take the slope and I
calculate it exactly you can do you can
do closed form you can go do it and I'm
simplifying in the regime of operation
the state-of-the-art results for this I
was in John stock this morning and I
already noticed that people mean this is
considered sort of already not there if
you did because if you did then my say
essentially they are the right ones they
are optimal up to this logarithm factor
so our results are only sort of better
this is the optimal composition theorem
and the only difference really really
here is that instead of 1 over Delta I
have epsilon delta x delta I mean
usually epsilon theta is sort of this is
the dominating factor epsilon root K so
if you put this as your epsilon tilde so
this basically says that you don't have
to pay a price in log 1 over Delta you
don't pay anyone a logarithmic price in
Delta you as a delta could be as much as
the same order as your epsilon up to a
constant then you don't even pay that
logarithmic cost and so it messed you
might have a saving of this log factor
so if you ignored it that's fine so you
you can even safely say that you're fine
already another application of the
composition theorem is for many
mechanisms I can hand compose the
mechanisms in see what I get so I can do
this for love plus I can do this for
staircase I can do for Gaussian they all
these three mechanisms and many more
yield the same value so it's true that
the gaussians once typically are
involved like this but that was because
there was it
not as sharp for concentration analysis
he'll this given the differential
privacy constraints do very sharp bounds
on the on the conditional probability
distribution all along the moment
generating function so the traditional
method for measure concentrations were
involving first and second moments as
umas but because in this case I have
such tight control over the entire
moment generating function I can use
charge for concentration theorems in
particular it's a mouth bound with a
carefully tuned parameter I have such
tight control over my moment generating
function so I could use something that
you are not bound to tightly handle the
measures once i do that then I many you
can actually get this kind of from here
to here just by doing that kind of a
measure oh I'm time in Thea said she's
lowing the talk so I forgot all about my
pack all right so um sure sorry I
completely skipped here so you can also
do a direct sharp concentration analysis
sir paper is available okay but I really
want to go back to the staircase
mechanism what was that all about where
did this staircase shape come from then
what's happening and in community I come
from a really want intuition I want to
understand what's happening okay so for
that binary didn't gooo Doeg binary
everything was already nice so let's
take three outputs now q query output is
three possible values and let's say my
neighborhood is every pair oh okay so
every pair i really want to is I want to
provide privacy you could offer other
things like this one this one only two
pairs and stuff but let's say every pair
for now and now if now have three
diagrams because for three pairs of
tests to do output 1 output to output 1
output three or put 2 or put three so
three tests so I have to draw a sort of
three curves and now there is a
trade-off you can hit the triangle fully
here here but this one will be very bad
you will be along the 45 degree line so
the diagonals start having a tension
between them you can never be fully sort
of we make use full use of the privacy
in any of all of them you just can't do
that there's a trade-off and so all
three can
not be the full triangular region this
case 3 but in general this is true even
definitely one more and so this is our
main result so I should I should back
off and say so you could say maybe there
is a black belt like theorem 4 3 ternary
hype experiments the answer is no so if
you have a 3 valued three hypotheses and
you look at the entire three dimensional
error region in one dominates one
mechanism dominates another that's not
enough to say Markov chain relationship
marketing is much stronger than that and
another legendary Berkeley statistician
lecom work quite a bit on it the seventh
condition several ways of dominations
but the markov chain domination is too
strong to get for who is a very special
case of binary input it was very special
case but all these all see curves are
within the triangle so that gives me a
handle so they're not arbitrary curves
and I can say the following the stay
there so give me any three curves so
that gives me give me a mechanism that I
can both plot 3 para seekers for the
three different experiments the three
hypothesis tests I can construct our
staircase mechanism I will define
precisely what it is a staircase
mechanism you know now is the time to
define an abstract staircase mechanism
previously you had this noise hiding in
your mind a staircase mechanism is any
probability distribution that can only
take on previously you could take any
values as long as it between either the
epsilon e to the negative epsilon but
now I let them take only three values
the ratio can only take on either each
of the epsilon on you to the negative
epsilon of one only three values it's
very combinatorial i'll call this as my
generals notions of staircase mechanisms
and for any given mechanism i can pick
one of these turkeys mechanisms that
will dominate it in a markov chain sets
turns out for the special case and this
is true for not just turn or even turn
it was an example this is true for
arbitrary inputs and turns out for the
special case where we had this nice
structure the sort of lattice integer
structure or real value structure and
you mini costs to sort of minimum
there's only one staircase that you get
pic even though there are many there's a
natural one and that's the one
monotonically decreasing and sort of
that sort of the intuition that goes
back to why staircases were the right
now is adding data independent macadam
so I'm trying to understand the theorem
that's on the slide so this said that
you think the theorem is not specific to
ternary know what are the conditions
okay so let me be precise so let's say
will be precise about this statement
here so we can do it for ternary so
there are three output values for the
query and I can take from there to any
number of outputs in the output of the
privatization mechanism so there's a
probability transition that's my
mechanism and the mic this is sort of
important that my privacy definitions
are on every pair right so for example
if you follow sort of MN we can discuss
this too so I this is a condition that
my privacy and furthermore it's
homogeneous that means if epsilon zero
and all of them it's not epsilon 1
epsilon 2 epsilon 3 things will change I
mean there's a generalization of this
but I'm making homogeneous conditions
and furthermore on every pair so if you
have K query outputs then you could say
that our K choose two pairs and all of
them are tightly controlled because I
every pair i have a epsilon zero privacy
yes so what is the relation between this
and the university optimal mechanism
because we don't have a university of
chemo mechanism for the case of a
ternary input that is probably visible
yeah so you say things i think is there
is a stir it's not visas boy depends on
the mechanism so scared is the family
it's combinatorial a defined just the
way the devastated the way susan 40 from
done from from an appropriate from a
class so i'm using staircase mechanism
as a class it's like a that's the same
sense in which we used it early there
was a parameter gamma so it's like a
class of
a family of 97 in English which sorry
yeah you can see it's sort of the
glasses the characterization of
practices with proper to being yeah you
could restrict it and then it's it's a
class I think rigor is class but it's a
restriction it's a comparator oriole
restriction on what values the
probabilities can take this is fun again
have like this a single parameter like
in the one query case actually um you
know let's so it depends on what your
utility is again oh and that's really
another law I want to however journal
paper out before I say that so very
untidy later this month will have
something and then I'd be happy to share
it and you can see all the precise all
details there we I know yeah we can
answer those things too okay let me
summarize I think I well then well over
my policies budget so we looked at a
staircase mechanism characterization of
fundamental mechanisms we looked at
Universal ality in a first certain
limited sense it's a cost framework and
with the right intuition using the
operational lens I can go back and try
to understand the universality in a
markov chain frameworks you can simulate
things and yeah I'm particularly happy
the workshop is at Berkeley's legendary
statisticians Blackwell and alaikum
Berkeley's from Cal and another way to
think of the or desserts as sort of
converses to name on Pearson in Neyman
Pearson you're given the statistics of
the channel and you try to find the best
schemes to find false alarm this
protections here I give you false alarm
is detection I try to do the minimum
variance or something like on the
channel itself so if you're going to
think of it you can think of it a
certain converse to Neyman Pearson okay
so papers are online and this is really
work with two people my graduate
student shawn gann who's actually my
graduated student so let's be precise
sean is right here this so and my
colleague same oh he's also actually as
fun to work with as he is on this
picture he'll be here tomorrow he said
Stanford giving their color pimped up
today and I really want to acknowledge a
very helpful discussions I'm new to this
area oh so sort of yeah it's completely
new actually and I've been helped by
very generous discussions and the
comments from Kamala Khan and Adam and
from Morris thank you so much yes sorry
I want this stiffness Camille
enforceability results for data the end
University yeah I always worry that I
don't know the literature enough what
are these impossibility I know there are
some and so we have 44 they take
independent University of your own
mechanisms when we have some
possibilities of rolling out almost all
course the existence of such share our
mechanisms for almost awkward one
account for is almost this is probably
the only career that has such thick
address now but the
these impossibility results we have some
impossibility results for data with
dependent mechanisms but but the general
results are only for data independent
mechanism so I wonder if this can give
us some light into I'm sure except I
need to know what this ok we can I would
love to I I'll be the first to say i
have actually very little very limited
now i'm not out of time I'm acting I
keep trying but it takes a while for me
to read them the writing style is quite
different actually so it takes time and
Adam knows all about it so having
straddled different areas so we have to
chat about it so it's quite somewhat
different and but the math is similar so
we'll be happy to chat more questions